cuando en la vida diaria la gente habla
acerca de perímetro déjame escribir aquí
arriba perímetro peri metro usualmente
se refiere a lo que rodea una cierta
área por ejemplo a una barda oa una reja
pero en matemáticas cuando hablamos
acerca de perímetro nos referimos algo
relacionado pero no es exactamente igual
no sólo nos referimos al objeto que
rodea sino la longitud de lo que rodea
es decir cuando tenemos que recorrer
para darle la vuelta a la figura vamos a
ver algunos ejemplos aquí tenemos un
triángulo ahí están los tres lados y
además nos marcan que los tres lados
miden lo mismo 4 4 y 4 podemos pensar
que son 4 pies 4 pies y 4 pies si
quisiéramos calcular su perímetro
tenemos que ver cuánto necesitamos
recorrer para rodearlo y eso sería 4 + 4
le voy a poner aquí 4 más 4 más 4 de
modo que su perímetro sería igual a 12
pies vale porque aquí las unidades son
pies te recomiendo ahorita pausa
el vídeo para intentar calcular el
perímetro de estas tres figuras de acá
vale bueno vamos a pasar con esta estoy
acá es un rectángulo sus lados miden 35
este también mide 3 porque el rectángulo
y 5 que es lo mismo que este de acá para
calcular su perímetro tendríamos que
sumar 35 35 déjame pensar que las
unidades están en metros todos éstos
están en metros metros metros déjame
poner esa m un poco más bonita
entonces el perímetro sería 5 metros
este de acá más 3 metros este de acá más
5 metros este más 3 metros este de acá 5
y 3 son 8 85 son 13 y 3 son 16 de modo
que el perímetro sería 16 metros pasemos
ahora a este pentágono es un pentágono
regular pues nos muestran que todos los
lados miden lo mismo y déjame inventar
una unidad nada más para divertirnos un
poco más que sean los blues
entonces la longitud de cada uno de
estos lados es 22 no está ésta es una
unidad que me estoy inventando justo
para este problema a lo mejor nunca la
has visto menos seguro nunca la has
visto porque la acabo de inventar pero
bueno también podemos calcular el
perímetro de este pentágono en cruz y
misma idea lo que tenemos que hacer es
sumar las longitudes de sus lados sería
dos más dos más dos más dos más dos esa
es una forma de pensarlo dos más dos más
dos más dos más dos pero también podemos
pensarlo como sigue como tiene cinco
lados y cada uno mide 2 - entonces
podemos hacer la multiplicación 55 por x
2 - de luz de modo que el perímetro
sería igual a 10 de luz entonces se
puede pensar tanto como una suma dos más
dos más dos más dos más dos como una
multiplicación 5 por 2 y nux bueno
pasemos a la última figura que es
bastante más irregular no es nada que
conozcamos pero bueno nos dan las
medidas de sus lados y por lo tanto
podemos encontrar su perímetro para
darle la vuelta a esta figura tenemos
que recorrer 14 2 más 2 1 + 4 + 2 más 2
más 46 más 4 más
6 aquino le puse unidades pero no
importa vamos a sumar quedaría 145 2 729
más 4 13 619 entonces el perímetro de
esta figura sería 1919 que pues quién
sabe no le hemos puesto unidades pero si
le pusiéramos sería 19 de éstas
unidades